[Music]  go  [Music]  it was a seven and I'm always  here for you too you're just pissed off  because you want to hang out with Steve  that's insane that's blasphemous food on  Pizza hello this is nothing in the  secretary and Treasure of Hawkins middle  IV Club  I was with him when the earthquake hit  does it matter he asks I'm here in the  territories  I didn't realize it was such an honor to  go trick-or-treating with you if I  played if I get one of those cool  t-shirts Ninja  foreign  idiot Steve Harrington I just mean I'm  glad you were with Mike  you know I needed to lose weight anyway  he's not like you Hopper I made this  choice  and I would choose it again  wow